participate in medical research as
subjects if we do understand genes how
much do we want to be able to engineer
there's a country we can't continue to
borrow seven percent of the whole
economy which is what we're borrowing
now we can only raise the level of our
dialogue a cool doodle things I take my
bumper stickers off our cars person on
the car is facing away from the person
reading a bumper sticker as though to
say here is my view it is not debatable
you read it I'm through discussing the
matter you have to be inclusive where
you come you can't say we're only gonna
do with that group for this group it's a
traditional American principle to say
that government is best which governs
least but frankly it can't govern least
unless it governs better bioengineered
food it's not that it's necessarily bad
but there should be some way of
regulating it any given situation there
conve adjust on a proper assessment you
know if you want proof of that the proof
does lion Arden to a certain extent we
should be spending less money on Wars
especially since we're no longer really
seriously threatened on terrorism is not
a public health friend relative to
cancer and heart disease and malaria and
so forth I hear too many people who say
these problems are too big we can't
possibly do anything about them but yes
we can we have millions of people
you